elastic tissue
abnormalities in the blood vessels of
patients with marfan's disease
predispose these patients to the
formation of aneurysms
these aneurysms may be found in a
variety of forms and locations
and dissecting processes involving the
ascending aorta
are not unusual this thirty-year-old man
was admitted to the hospital with a
history of severe substernal pain
radiating through to the back and down
into the lumbar region
one and a half years prior to admission
this was followed by transient numbness
and weakness in the right leg
but these symptoms subsided
spontaneously over the next several days
three weeks prior to admission he again
experienced an episode of severe
substernal pain
with radiation to the back renting a
graphic examination of the chest
demonstrated enlargement of his
ascending aorta
examination revealed the patient to be
six feet eight inches in height
with long slender hands fingers feet
and toes in both legs there was wide
separation between the anterior tibial
tubercle
and the inferior border of the patella
characteristic of marfan's disease
no abnormalities were noted in either
eye
the heart was slightly enlarged to
percussion and an early grade two
decrescendo diastolic murmur was heard
at the base
with radiation toward the apex the blood
pressure was 120 over 60 millimeters of
mercury
in both arms and all peripheral pulses
were present
and of a water hammer characteristic
intravenous contrast visualization of
the thoracic aorta
demonstrated aneurysmal dilatation of
almost the entire ascending portion
the transverse and descending portions
of the thoracic aorta
did not appear unusual there was no
retinographic evidence of a double
density characteristic of a dissecting
process
under general endotracheal anesthesia a
median sternotomy incision was made
the sternum was split with a levski
knife
the pericardium was opened
longitudinally
as the sternum was spread the aneurysmal
process was seen to extend from the
aortic valve annulus
to just proximal to the innominate
artery
this drawing illustrates the extent of
aneurysmal involvement
cardiopulmonary bypass was instituted
employing a disposable plastic
oxygenator primed with five percent
dextrose in distilled water
under normal thermic conditions
the vena cavi were drained by gravity
into the pump oxygenator
and a sump in the left ventricular apex
allowed for left heart decompression
oxygenated blood was returned to the
femoral artery
through a roller pump and cannulay were
used to perfuse the coronary arteries
during the proximal anastomosis
clamps were placed across the aorta
between the aneurysm and the innominate
artery
the aorta was divided between the clamps
the distal cut end of the aorta was
freed up to the innominate artery
and re-clamped
a small septum representing the distal
portion of the dissecting process
was excised a woven crimped decrim graft
of the appropriate size was selected
and anastomose to the distal cut end of
the aorta
employing an over and over suture of 3o
linear polyethylene
as demonstrated in this drawing
while the distal anastomosis was
performed the coronary arteries were
perfused
through the aneurysm itself from
coronary sinus blood
oxygenated by intermittent inflation of
the lungs
and by bronchial artery return to the
left side of the heart
over distension of the left heart during
the maneuver was prevented
by intermittent decompression through
the sump in the left ventricular apex
upon completion of the distal
anastomosis a vascular clamp was placed
across the graft
and the integrity of the anastomosis was
tested
the left ventricular sump was used to
evacuate the aneurysm
and the aneurysm was entered the double
walls of the true and false lumen were
seen with a tear in the inner wall
just above the aortic valve annulus the
cusps of the aortic valve were
relatively normal
aortic valvular insufficiency resulted
from prolapse of the cusps into the
ventricle
secondary to prolapse of their
attachments to the inner wall
this prolapse of the cusps in relation
to their normal position
is demonstrated in this illustration
coronary cannuli were inserted and
coronary profusion was begun
a major portion of the aneurysm was
excised leaving part of the outer wall
for future support of the graft
the graft was pulled down and cut to
length
the proximal anastomosis was begun
posteriorly
in such a manner as to pull the inner
wall with its attachment to the aortic
valve cusps
back into normal position during the
performance of the anastomosis
this anastomosis was also performed with
an over and over suture of 3-0 linear
polyethylene
incorporating both the inner and outer
walls of the aorta
obliterating the false lumen as the
prolapsed cusps were pulled back from
within the ventricle
as the anastomosis neared completion the
right coronary cannula was removed
but the left coronary cannula was left
in place as long as possible
in this manner excellent cardiac
contractions were maintained
immediately prior to completion of the
proximal anastomosis
the tourniquet on the superior vena cava
was released
and the left heart decompression was
stopped temporarily
to allow the heart to fill with blood
prior to tying this suture the clamp on
the distal aorta was released briefly
in order to allow the graft to fill in a
retrograde fashion
evacuating air from the graft
finally the proximal anastomosis was
completed and the clamp was removed from
the distal aorta
the sump in the left ventricular apex
was used to evacuate any air remaining
in the ventricle
following which it was removed
the completed operation is demonstrated
in this drawing
with the graft extending from the aortic
valve annulus
to the level of the innominate artery
the outer wall of the aneurysm was cut
to size
the proximal anastomosis was wrapped
with surgical hemostatic gauze
and the remaining portion of the outer
wall of the aneurysm was used to further
support the graft
the sternum was closed with interrupted
wire sutures
the chest was closed in layers
the patient's course following operation
was uneventful
retrograde contrast visualization of the
thoracic aorta was performed two weeks
following operation
and demonstrated satisfactory function
of the graft without evidence of aortic
valvular insufficiency
the patient was discharged three days
later with a blood pressure of 120 over
75 millimeters of mercury in both
arms and has remained asymptomatic